in what way do you think
these large language models and the
thing they give birth to in the AI space
will change this Human Experience The
Human Condition
the things we've talked across many
podcasts about that makes life so damn
interesting and Rich
love fear fear of death all of it uh if
we could just begin kind of thinking
about how does it change
for the good and the bad The Human
Condition
Human Society is extremely complicated
we have come from
a hunter-gatherer Society to an
agricultural and farming Society
where the goal of most professions was
to eat and to survive
and with the Advent of Agriculture the
ability to live together in societies
humans could suddenly be
valued for different skills if you don't
know how to hunt
but you're an amazing potterer then you
fit in society very well because you can
sort of make your pottery and you can
barter it for rabbits that somebody else
got and the person who hunts the rabbits
doesn't need to make Bots because you're
making all the parts
and that's specialization of humans is
what shaped modern society
and with the Advent of currencies and
governments and you know credit cards
and Bitcoin you basically now have the
ability to exchange value for the kind
of productivity that you have
so basically I make things that are
desirable to others I can sell them and
buy back food shelter Etc
with AI
the concept of I am my profession
might need to be revised
because I defined my profession in the
first place I something that Humanity
needed that I was uniquely capable of
delivering but the moment we have ai
systems able to deliver
these goods for example writing a piece
of software or making a self-driving car
or interpreting the human genome
then that frees up more of
human time for other Pursuits
this could be Pursuits that are still
valuable to society I could basically be
10 times more productive at interpreting
genomes and do a lot more
or I could basically say oh great the
interpreting genomes part of my job now
only takes me five percent of the time
instead of 60 of the time so now I can
do more creative things I can explore
not new career options but maybe new
directions from my research lab I can
sort of be more productive contribute
more to society
and if you look at this giant
pyramid that we have built on top of the
subsistence economy
what fraction of U.S jobs are going to
feeding all of the US less than two
percent
basically the the gain in productivity
is such that 98 of the economy is beyond
just feeding ourselves and that
basically means that
we kind of have built these system of
inter dependencies of needed or useful
or valued Goods that sort of make the
economy run that the vast majority of
wealth goes to other
what we now call needs but used to be
wants
so basically I want to fly a drone I
want to buy a bicycle I want to buy a
nice car I want to have a nice home I
want to tether Etc so
and and then sort of what is my direct
contribution to my eating I mean I'm I'm
doing research on the human genome I
mean this will help humans it will help
all Humanity but how is that helping the
person who's giving me poultry or
vegetables so in a way I see AI as
perhaps leading to a dramatic rethinking
of human society
if you think about sort of the economy
being based on intellectual Goods that
I'm producing
what if AI can produce a lot of these
intellectual goods and satisfies that
need does that now free humans for more
artistic expression for more emotional
maturing for
basically having a better work-life
balance being able to show up for your
two hours of work a day or two hours of
work like three times a week with like
immense rest and preparation and
exercise and you're sort of clearing
your mind and telling you have these two
amazingly creative hours you basically
show up at the office as your AI is busy
answering your phone call making all
your meetings you know revising all your
papers Etc and then you show up for
those creative hours and you're like all
right autopilot I'm on
and then you can basically do so so much
more that you would perhaps otherwise
never get to because you're so
overwhelmed with these mundane aspects
of your of your job so I feel that AI
can truly transform The Human Condition
from realizing that
we don't have jobs anymore we now have
vocations
and there's this beautiful analogy of
three people laying bricks and somebody
comes over and asks the first one what
are you doing he's like oh I'm laying
bricks second one what are you doing I'm
building a wall
and the third one what are you doing I'm
building this beautiful cathedral
so in a way the first one has a job the
last one has a vocation
and if you ask me what are you doing oh
I'm editing a paper then I have a job
what are you doing
um understanding human disease circuitry
I have a vocation so in a way being able
to allow us to enjoy more of our
vacation
by taking away offloading some of the
job part
of our daily activities so we all become
the the Builder of cathedrals correct
yeah and we follow intellectual Pursuits
artistics Pursuits I wonder what how
that really changed at a scale of
several billion people
everybody playing in the space of ideas
in the space of creations
so ideas maybe for some of us maybe you
and I are in the job of ideas but other
people are in the job of experiences
other job other people in the the job of
emotions of dancing of creative artistic
expression of you know skydiving and you
name it so basically these
again the beauty of human diversity is
exactly that that what rocks my boat
might be very different from what rocks
other people's boat and what I'm trying
to say is that maybe AI will allow
humans to truly
like not just look for but Find meaning
and sort of you don't need to work but
you need to keep your brain at ease and
the way that your brain will be at ease
is by dancing and creating this amazing
you know movements or creating these
amazing paintings or creating I don't
know something that that sort of changes
that that touches at least one person
out there that sort of shapes Humanity
through that process
and instead of working your you know
mundane programming job where you like
hate your boss and you hate your job and
you say you hate that darn program Etc
you're like well I don't need that I can
you know offload that and I can now
explore something that will actually be
more beneficial to human to humanity
because the mundane Parts can be
offloaded I wonder if it localizes our
uh all the things you've mentioned all
the vocations so you mentioned that you
and I might be playing in the space of
ideas but there's two ways to play in
this piece of ideas both of which we're
currently engaging and so one is the
communication of that to other people it
could be a classroom full of students
but it could be a podcast it could be
something that's uh that's shown on
YouTube and so on or it could be just
the act of sitting alone and playing
with ideas in your head or maybe with a
loved one having a conversation that
nobody gets to see the experience of
just sort of looking up at the sky and
wondering uh different things maybe
quoting some philosophers from the past
and playing with those little ideas and
that little exchange is forgotten
forever but you got to experience it and
maybe
I wonder if it localizes that exchange
of ideas for that with AI it'll become
less and less valuable to communicate
with a large group of people that you
will live life intimately and and richly
just with that Circle of meat bags that
you seem to love
so the first is even if you're alone in
a forest having this amazing thought
when you exit that Forest the baggage
that you carry has been shifted has been
altered by that thought
when I bike to work in the morning I
listen to books
and I'm alone no one else is there I'm
having that experience by myself and yet
in the evening when I speak with someone
an idea that was formed there could come
back
sometimes when I fall asleep I fall
asleep listening to a book and in the
morning I'll be full of ideas that I
never even process consciously I'll
process them unconsciously and they will
shape that baggage that I carry that
will then shape my interactions and
again affect ultimately all of humanity
in some Butterfly Effect minute kind of
way
so that's one aspect
the second aspect is
Gatherings so basically you and I are
having a conversation
which feels very private but we're
sharing with the world
and then later tonight you're coming
over and we're having a conversation
that will be very public with dozens of
other people but we will not share with
the world yeah
so in a way which one's more private the
one here or the one there here there's
just two of us but a lot of others
listening there a lot of people speaking
and thinking together and bouncing off
each other and maybe that will then
impact your millions of you know uh
audience
through your next conversation and
I think that's part of the beauty of
humanity the fact that no matter how
small how alone how broadcast
immediately or later on something is
it still percolates through the human
psyche
human gatherings
all throughout human history there's
been gatherings
I wonder how those Gatherings have
impacted the direction of human
civilization it's just uh thinking of
in the early days of the Nazi party
it was a small collection of people
Gathering
and the uh the kernel of an idea in that
case an evil idea
I gave birth to something that actually
had a transformative impact on all the
human civilization and then there's a
similar kind of gatherings that lead to
positive transformations